lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
introducirlos a lo que pienso que es una
de las ideas más necesitadas en la
ciencia de la computación y es
recursividad la manera en que definimos
esta función factorial en los últimos
vídeos es interactiva fue una definición
interactiva estuvimos haciendo
iteraciones para diferentes valores de
la variable y luego le sumábamos uno al
valor de iu y multiplica vamos eso por
el valor original del producto y
continuamos con esas iteraciones todas
las veces desde que el producto valía 1
y multiplica vamos cada vez este valor
hasta que se multiplicó por el valor de
número y el resultado quedaba en esta
variable producto lo que voy a hacer
ahora es reescribir este programa y lo
que es padre de las funciones voy a
reescribir esta función lo que es padre
de las funciones es que en esta función
decimos mira nos regresa el valor del
factorial de un número y en realidad no
nos importa cómo está escrito este
código y cualquier cosa que esta función
use no importa cómo está implementada
siempre y cuando está implementada
correctamente no nos debería preocupar
cómo está escrita así que mientras las
implementaciones que están hechas dentro
de este código funcionen no importa que
estén hechas de diferentes maneras no
deberían afectar el comportamiento de
esta función sigamos adelante tratando
de definir esta función recursiva mente
y creo que encontrarán esto realmente
fascinante y lo que voy a hacer es un
poquito diferente también voy a poner
unos condicionales aquí y voy a decir
bueno en un sentido la recursividad es
profunda y complicada y en otro sentido
es más simple que cualquier cosa dejen
de poner todo esto más abajo y siempre
tenemos que pensar en un caso básico en
una situación en la que número tenga el
menor valor posible para esta función y
podríamos decir mira sin número y número
y número digamos que es menor o igual
que 1 si es menor o igual a 1 regresa 1
return 1 osea definimos ese factorial
como 1 y así tendremos el mismo
comportamiento que la función que
habíamos escrito antes en la función
anterior sin número era igual a 10 o 1
negativo 2 negativo definíamos el
factorial como 1 y de volvíamos al
factorial igual a 1 y eso es exactamente
lo que estamos haciendo aquí regresamos
1 sin número es igual o menor que 1 y
esto también define nuestro caso básico
voy a escribir un comentario aquí
este es nuestro caso básico y en un
momento veremos a lo que me refiero con
caso básico y lo que sigue es la parte
emocionante de la recursividad si el
número no es igual o menor a 1 podría
escribir aquí el if
bueno mejor voy a escribir él
sin números no es igual o menor a 1 voy
a regresar algo diferente voy a devolver
return lo que voy a regresar es ese
número por el factorial de ese número
menos 1 número por factorial de número
menos 1
ahora la razón por la que esto es
fascinante es que yo defino algo usando
ese algo así que defina la función
llamada factorial y la define usando la
definición de la función factorial o sea
se está refiriendo a sí misma esto es lo
que hacen las funciones recursivas pero
explicaremos esto en un diagrama en el
siguiente vídeo para que le encuentran
el sentido a esto esto tiene que
funcionar porque si ponemos un 1 o un 0
en número les regresará 1 que pasa sin
número es 2 bueno sin números 2
adquirirá mira número no es menor o
igual a 1 así que continuamos aquí abajo
y regresamos 2 x factorial de 2 menos
uno o factorial de uno entonces esto
llamará a la función factorial otra vez
y el factorial de uno es 1 así que
regresará 2 por 1 2 por 1 2
esto funciona bien parados tratemos para
3 si hacemos factorial de 3 se pasará a
esta parte porque 3 no es
con igual a 1 y regresar a 3 x factorial
de 3 menos uno que es 2 y ya vimos que
regresa el resultado correcto cuando
hacemos factorial de 2 y el resultado de
factorial de dos es dos así que
regresamos 3 por 2 que es igual a 6 y es
el factor y'all de 3 espero que ya están
captando la idea y el factorial de 4
funcionará de la misma manera 4 por el
factorial de 3 sabemos que funciona bien
para el factorial de 3 y sólo para
probarles que no estoy haciendo alguna
especie de locura y que esto realmente
funciona tratemos de correr el programa
dejen de borrar esto que tenemos aquí es
el código anterior ya no nos sirve y
dejen de correr el programa todo lo que
hice fue redefinir la función factorial
pero la redefinir recursiva mente como
una función recursiva creo que no tengo
que cambiar los comentarios así que
déjenme salvarla y correr la vamos a
hacer que el intérprete ejecute este
programa para ver si realmente hace
esperamos que haga ok está corriendo
bien y nos pide que tecleamos algo
digamos que queremos el factorial de 5
120 así que vemos que es un programa de
factorial no importa lo que pusimos allá
adentro nos regresa la respuesta
correcta pero lo que es realmente padre
es que ahora lo está haciendo recursiva
mente cuando hago factorial de 6 dice ok
factorial de 66 es menor o igual a 0
claro que no así que continúa en esta
cláusula else y entonces regresa 6 por
el factorial de 5 dice ok déjenme
recordar 6 por el factorial de 5 y viene
aquí para saber el factorial de 5 y el
factorial de 5 es 5 por el factorial de
4 y el factorial de 4 es 4 por el
factorial de 3 y así sucesivamente hasta
que llega al factorial de 1 que es 1 y
entonces realmente regresa 6 por 5 por 4
por 3 por 2 por 1